let's bring up another news article what
else do we have and then we'll finish
up here man uh let's go with that uh
logan paul
what's he doing now did he sell his home
does it say what does it say here
can you zoom in a little thank you
brother the pandemic has filled a
dramatic new wave of high-profile
migration
sending tech workers to texas wall
street types to florida
and youtube provocateur logan paul to
uh puerto rico paul and influence
entertainers told his 2.8 million
youtube subscribers tuesday he was
leaving los angeles and moving to the
heaven on earth of dorado
so it to me this is a community about 30
minutes west of san juan has become a
favorite spot of wealthy
mainlanders to me uh this
sounds like he did
ayahuasca and just took off and went to
puerto rico he's making a choice he had
now
yeah um i gotta tell you you know um
i first of all love puerto rico it's a
beautiful
place but i understand they have some
weather issues down there
where you might not want to build a
super expensive home
yeah because the hurricanes whip through
there pretty good
however um you know it's a beautiful
spot oh yeah puerto rico is beautiful
man they got that three kings day tris
which is also a gang uh in part of
america but
it's crazy here in california paying
taxes and for what paul said on his show
impulsive the streets are not fixed
homeless people everywhere
a darth well i'm surprised you knew that
word but i respect that logan well done
a darth of unemployment coveted not
handled
i don't love it yeah man there's a lot
of things about california that lead it
to
that i think have led to some of its
decline
in some of our minds i mean for me
number one was definitely taxes yeah i
just didn't feel like paying taxes to
uh just such a a place that to me it
just becomes so
just too far lopsided just i agree out
for blood
not as creative as it as i felt like it
maybe once was um too much nepotism i
feel like not enough chances for the
regular person that's moving there
um and i could be wrong i i could be
totally wrong but those are just
thoughts that have been in my head
no am i saying they're accurate for me
the taxes i was like i i didn't mind
paying the taxes
when i knew what my taxes were going
towards right
why am i paying taxes and stepping over
homeless people wherever not it's not
just in one part of the city now
everywhere
why am i why am i meeting up yeah man
they're making communities yeah why am i
paying taxes
and it's so dirty do you know what i
mean like if i'm paying this money
it's a lot of money yeah a lot of money
then what am i getting from it and i
wasn't getting anything and not only
that man honestly
it's like i said and i should have left
a couple years ago i never felt like i
was really part of the cool
kids and i felt like
i feel so much more creative and relaxed
here
because i don't feel like i'm competing
all the time oh yeah
i'm not waking up wondering what other
people are doing or a great point do you
know what i mean
yeah that part of my day is gone it's
like i'm just a little creative
and maybe i can spend some time taking
care of myself yeah
um did you wake up also and worry about
what other people were doing
and what other people i just found like
i'm i'm like why am i
in my own head competing with these
people yeah we're not competing
do you know what i mean right i haven't
done that here
yeah i think uh i think well
i stole my apartment there so it's like
i i'll probably go back and spend some
time there especially
as the summer comes back and um and it's
a nice you know to get to the beach and
also to do
do podcasting and stuff like that hope
you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you